I just cannot predict the future and the
games they've kicked off yeah and it's a
French defense ah from the world
champion yeah and Magnus does this from
time to time not normally uh in the
biggest clashes uh not normally when he
wants to stay solid it's often when he
wants to try and win games the French
defense and this will be a surprise to
kakesh you think
I think this will be not a massive
surprise I think gukesh has come
prepared for this uh I'm very curious
what he chooses just very quickly though
that last graphic there was a certain
number in there that spoke me Gary was
only 1677. it must have been
26.77 I was that was a quick improvement
over two years
um yeah there was a little typo in there
for everybody watching I'm impressed you
noticed yeah I'm attention to detail
yeah that's good and meanwhile one of
the main lines of the French defense uh
the name of this is this the classical
variation yes I think this is actually a
ginger GM Special by the way if Simon
was Ariel would be licking his chops
because he's at this position a bunch of
times especially with a quick A6 B5 I
think that's right up his alley he's
been playing it since he was a teenager
himself Simon Williams from the black
side yeah I thought you waited a little
bit though until white committed the
king
I've actually played this with like I
think I played this against castenyuk in
in Isle of Man you can check that you
see if that's in the database yeah as
far as I know this is still quite a
well-known position it's still very
theoretical
um the one thing you don't want to do
um as you guys alluded to is to Castle
the king at the moment with white you
definitely don't want to go queenside
because that's where Black's pawns are
pushing you might Castle there later but
only when the center has clarified
itself so here as white you tended to
play a bit of a waiting game you tend to
see what black is going to do first
before deciding which side to put your
King on this is again as far as I know
one of the most popular moves Pawn takes
Pawn just again asking Magnus Carlson
are you going to take this Pawn back
with the black dark squared Bishop
you're going to take with your knight
once you have a bit more information
then you can decide when to castle with
white okay he takes with the bishop
Magnus normally this isn't a good idea
normally you want to keep dark squares
Bishops on the board as black because
Black's light squared Bishop if you
looked at it on the C8 Square it's just
locked in doesn't have a great future
but because black is a bit cramped in
the middle of the board you have to just
trade off pieces you need a bit more
space otherwise your pieces will be
fighting for the same squares so
um still very standard stuff here and
now I think white can Castle White's
Queen can also move I've seen that one
before a bunch of options here for good
fish but both players have done their
homework clearly
yeah definitely and uh you're right uh
just lighting the queen two squares
across to attack the Knight is the most
popular move this one was uh number two
in the list of choices
so what just brings this bishop out and
he's keeping Magnus guessing now go cash
uh Magnus as black he's gonna be
thinking okay are you gonna go kingside
you're gonna go Queen side which way are
you going with the white king and uh
it's it's hard to formulate a plan it's
black as well you have to make that
decision does your king stay in the
center does your king go to its kind of
usual home over there on the right it's
lots of strategic choices which will
have long-term consequences
usually white has a small advantage in
these types of positions because if you
look at the center white has this port
on E5 the furthest Advanced Pawn out of
any that clamps down a black position
also the dark squares white has pretty
decent control over the dark skies in
the center and black princess queen a
waiting game definitely a waiting game
and I just wanted to add one very
important point to why also white is
slightly better I mean take a look at
the light Square Bishop that black has
it's bad and this is always a point of
contention between players who play the
caracan like me and the French defense
and it's like a running joke you know
and we have all sorts of uh kind of
memes going on about this uh Bishop like
there's there's one that kind of goes
you know how can you tell if I said well
actually because there's all these
openings and they go oh French defense
is missing and there we see the pawn
attacking and uh everyone goes well
where is where is French defense and
some caracan goes wait wait wait for it
the light squared Bishop is bad and the
French defense suddenly appears from no
one goes no no no I think you'll find
it's a chess bear joke
I don't know why I'm going on about it I
found it very funny that's the big
difference right between the French
defense and most openings today you just
have one bad piece and I think this is
Marcus's idea to try and trade off his
worst piece and uh I mean he can play it
now for example yeah it does so that's
why we talk about bad pieces because if
you figure out which pieces are your
worst then you can come up with easy
plans and he wants to trade it off for
whites very strong Bishop in the center
okay if the Bishops disappear black has
a very healthy position the Knight can
jump into the center black has gained a
lot of space on this side of the board
and because the center's blocked he
doesn't actually need to rush to Castle
his King another thing we've seen from
Magnus in recent months he definitely
doesn't rush to Castle keeps his
opponent guessing so should go cash now
take that bishop or should he wait
good question
um I guess you can take or there is a
bit of pressure on this bishop it's
attacked by Black's Knight and Bishop so
I guess you could
I was gonna say just defend it but
kakesh he's a very aggressive player uh
when he wants to be and he's pushing
forward he's going for the black king
already so he's trying to open up Lions
the White Queen and Rook both sit on
this f file so if by pushing the spawn
forward he's trying to open things up
and isn't this the the strategy that's
that's given but prags much success
against Magnus just attacking him and it
worked for Eric I see yesterday Eric I
could have gone on the defense that was
fine but he went on the attack and it
worked he beat Magnus ah what do you
think Lawrence Strong move well I mean
it's it's it's a positive move it's a
move that says
I'm not really afraid I'm not going to
be too passive against you because
that's where Magnus really does the
damage when you're overly scared of him
when you're on the front foot against
Magnus
you've got all the chances he still has
to find accurate moves now of course
he's very capable of finding those moves
but he's still Human After All and this
is the move you really want to play if
you can play in a French so I love the
move I don't know objectively how well I
mean the bar says it's slightly better
for black but I
yeah I mean we have uh people like
Lauren fresenay playing in Matthews
Bartel a Polish Grandmaster Master
vasilis uh
Demetrius a great Grandmaster and Robo
Fontaine it's another French Grandmaster
so yeah everyone is uh well challenging
black because I guess you have to
because if black is is just trading off
those light squared Bishops then he's
kind of maximized absolutely everything
that he wants from the opening and
Ivanka so Pawn takes porn was played by
Magnus fair enough capturing a pawn has
this been seen before and if so what
what kind of scores are we uh used to
seeing does white win a lot of games
here black
okay so here are the stats so one takes
Pawn very much the top move and it's a
37 win rate for wise right 44 for black
wow uh so yeah
stats are not in White's favor no no
maybe go cash has other ideas maybe he
hasn't analyzed those numbers I mean I
guess white clear can take the pawn back
or I was about to suggest as well this
knight move very natural uh now you've
temporarily sacrificed a pawn but black
now has an isolated Pawn in the center
yeah if you can capture this one you'll
gain time as well against the black
queen
very tense Wow Let's go back to the
place I like your Cash's opening choice
though he's not scared of Magnus
and just defending that one with the
black knight let's also take a look at
their aim chess head-to-head stats go
cash and Magnus Carlsen we do know
Magnus Carlsen is fantastic in the end
game but good cash definitely not bad
himself and I actually noticed he's
quite close to minus on most stats how
Sensational is that for a 16 year old I
mean yeah it's very promising signs uh I
guess the biggest difference is just the
end game but also the resourcefulness
that's something that will come with age
for gokesh and games you'll have more
experience you'll study them more with
the audio you get also resourcefulness
you get a bit trickier the older you get
you get a bit more Wily and you learn
how to set practical problems for your
opponent in tough positions so yeah
impressive what do you think Lawrence
yeah no of course I mean to play like
this at 16 is is just uh it's it's it's
mind-blowing it's uh yeah he's just as
we saw in the graphic in the intro what
just a couple of points of where he is
record
uh but
he's got a bit more um longevity about
him it seems why he's an interesting
story which we can discuss another day
because when we got to that rating at 16
everybody was saying that this kid is
going to be and he he didn't manage to
find that next level yeah for whatever
reason but you have a feeling that with
gukesh and the system and the support
network that he has not just you know
even so with the tweets right he's got
the whole country behind him so I think
having that support system is actually
massive and um he's got the Talon and
look at him he's just he's he's doing a
you know he's trying to literally rip
magnus's heart out with these moves he's
the F5 E6 so he tried to I mean
fair play you've got to give him credit
yeah definitely and uh well we see
Magnus just try to look up the position
by advancing the pawn and uh Lauren's
kind of also mentioned the support
system and I just kind of also wanted to
talk about a story that gukesh said
um when he lost that critical game to
Abdul satauroff he he left the playing
venue in tears and he was just
absolutely distraught and uh late in the
night he got a telephone call from vishi
Anand wow who said uh hey you know can
we can I come over and uh he came over
to kakash's room and they had a chat and
and just gave him some advice showed him
some games where he too had been in that
situation where he'd overpressed and I
thought that is such a beautiful touch
actually that the legend himself you
know he's not only inspired this new
generation has actually come and helped
them yeah I I really appreciated this
story and I thought you know it's
fantastic sick what a team effort yeah
it's no coincidence that India producing
all these youngsters when you have
personalities like that who are willing
to help absolutely a lot of selfless
coaches out there who put in their time
for good cash for Prague who've kind of
made them who they are today
and uh meanwhile in the game like we
said Lawrence I mean it's just so
impressive what he's doing he does need
a follow-up however he's calmed down so
uh what would we be thinking here how
does white find compensation for the
pawn he's sacrificed yeah it's naughty I
mean my the first move that comes to
mind for me is I feel like I want to
take on A6 uh get rid of those Bishops
yeah just uh importantly of course he
can't take with the Knights he has to
take with the Rook can't take with the
queen either so Rook takes and then the
natural followers just to put the Rook
on D1 here to try and win back a pawn
um it's not oh it's not I I'm not in
love with it I don't look at it and
think wow this is fantastic yeah but I
also don't exactly know what you should
be doing here with white yeah um this is
one option you're right what else I mean
also I would be tempted to put my knight
in the middle of the board but it
doesn't actually do it doesn't actually
exactly it doesn't actually create
anything black can probably just castle
at some point and uh yeah also black at
some point can put his Knight in the
center of the board I'm not sure who
that favors
um yeah this is a critical moment gokash
needs a plan it also crossed my mind
that you can kind of go to the edge of
the board and start trying to uh attack
some pawns but again the question is
whether black can Castle safely I don't
think white has any way to kind of set
up the queen and attack this Pawn you're
just not in time unfortunately because
black has a discovered check along this
diagonal hitting the queen as well so
yeah it's it's definitely no obvious
moves shouting out kind of screaming out
to be played right now
and this is one but what else
uh you think have we seen this position
before we have seen it I mean there's
only a handful of games but uh in that
particular one particular game uh White
just uh centralized The Rook
so yeah is trying to do the idea that
Lawrence spoke about yep so indirect ah
attacking the sport sorry importantly
Bishop takes E3 Rook takes D3 is the
idea you don't have to take back with
the poor yeah take the Rook make use of
this pin
Black Knight can't recapture and yeah
this looks like a better version of the
variation we looked at just because now
this one is attacked twice you can't
defend it with the black Rook but white
can keep piling up on this Pawn if uh if
he wishes
so this looks like maybe go Cash's
safest option or at least one of the
most sensible he's thinking in this
position uh whether to bring his Rook to
the center
and uh yeah I mean you mentioned way
either and Wei is still very strong of
course but he's still the same rating
and I think that's a caution retail like
these top players they still have to
keep working not everyone's going to hit
the top level we mentioned go cash every
Galaxy Prague but
maybe one of them will hit 2800 not I
mean maybe all of them will hit 2800 but
there's no guarantee for any and I think
it's nice to have the Rivalry as well
just uh especially within India they're
kind of pushing each other to uh to
Greater Heights okay he plays a very
mysterious Rook movie that's a very
carpovian move that is that's that is
that is carp off to exceed doesn't work
but it yeah the spirit was that
I mean we all I think understand the
idea behind this move he's trying to
persuade Magnus to play Bishop takes
Bishop then after white recaptures the
white Rook on the C file it comes open
but Magnus is never ever going to
capture that no very strange you're
asking your opponent to do something but
it's you're making it pretty obvious
what your plan is
Magnus just immediately castles
in Wolf 19 another game where he castles
very late yeah yeah you normally don't
want to Castle past move 10 or 12 that's
what I was taught at least when I was
young but
it's strange do you think that was a
mouse slip by kokesh do you think he
wants to put that right on the D file no
but surely you have a plan now
it doesn't it does kind of feel like a
mouse lip to be honest with you because
I think we would have seen a bigger
reaction from him if he now slept he
he's looked calm the whole way through
so so where did he want to put it
well he chose but uh maybe one square to
the right so the D1 Square that's the
most natural at least by far and why is
that more natural than the c-square both
are covered by a Portland in front of it
um yeah so if we jump in just to show
this so in this position
so we were advocating the D file just
because uh next move for example if
black did the same as he did in the game
if Magnus castled now at the very least
you could play Bishop takes Bishop black
Caster recapture with the rook and now
the Rook is actually hitting a pawn so
you can actually regain a pawn and uh
here you have probably just equal
chances you hit the Knight you hit this
Pawn uh black and for example capture
this guy but we'll just see a bunch of
exchanges and probably an equal end game
uh so kakesh by putting his work on the
different square the square he chose
um if we go back to the game position
what's it doing here Magnus castled if
Magnus have played Bishop takes Bishop
now we finally understand why the Rook
is here because after Pawn takes
suddenly The Rook comes to life hits
this knight uh using this pin as well
but Magnus of course he'll never ever
take this bishop
what's your Rook doing here so is it
kind of protecting that Bishop then yeah
what I mean he pushes forward this is
the idea this is the only plan I think
to open up the Rook
um yeah so this Knight is not actually
attacking the bishop because of a pin
along this diagonal the Black Knight
can't move because the black queen will
drop
and if Bishop takes Bishop
now we see again an attack on this night
Magnus though gets out of the PIN
and uh not just does he get out of the
pin but he attacks this bishop he
attacks this Knight
looks very strong for black
element yeah there's one I think kokesh
was trying to be a bit too clever maybe
he should have just kept things simple
okay Bishop takes Bishop has been played
uh recaptures still a problem with this
Knight
still a problem with Knight takes Pawn
still a problem with the Knight coming
into the center
and blacks are pulling up yeah and uh
and one of the things that I also
noticed is that white is really lacking
choice because as you've highlighted
Black's pieces are very active and you
can't just like casually move back
Retreat the night that's under attack
because the Knight jumps into the D3
Square
and well that's going to favor Magnus
big time and so you can't do that so
you're gonna either you're either gonna
have to shuffle a piece over to protect
that Knight you can't even throw in
intermediate moves like Pawn takes porn
and go hey look I'm attacking your
knight because still that white knight
is under attack and
you can just capture recapture the pawn
the porn I think maybe even stronger is
to put the Black Knight into the center
hit the Queen the queen has to use the
square to protect her Knight and now you
just the capture and like you say Ivanka
just put someone attacked um this Pawn
looks very strong but actually it could
just drop off at some point in the next
few moves and okay we see this variation
on the board
we'll see this position in a moment
because she needs to move his Queen in
the game position and he's just gonna be
a pawn down
slightly surprised the computer says is
this much of an advantage but it just
must be because white has nothing for
his Pawn
and yeah we do see this position now uh
this is a threat sometimes black can
even start pushing pawns where he's
strongest
um okay good cash centralizes and
the acid test now is just take another
Pawn go two pawns up for Magnus
yeah looks possible so it's looking
really good for Magnus now and really
bad for new cash yeah
control he chose the wrong plan and it
was it was an interesting plan but it
was just a bit slow look at the clocks
as well yeah
I didn't like this Rook ac1 move I think
kukash had to play a lot more simply
Rook ad1 try and win the pawn back
wasn't much
um black was still doing fine but
now the onus is very much on the young
man to prove what he's got for the two
pawns you called it a karpovian move
what is that what was uh carpool Style
a lot of karpov's moves were what what
are known as prophylactic moves and what
that means is anticipating what your
opponent wants to do
so he was anticip if we go back to that
position David we'll probably have to
show that uh he was anticipating a trade
on D3 so if he is anticipating that the
c-line is going to get open then having
The Rook there already
benefits him because he's already got a
rook in perfect placement
it didn't quite work here the spirit was
right but the execution wasn't quite
right so but now the Rook gets free
and it is in that very nice seventh
heaven yeah yeah and the seventh rank
the problem is is that Black's pieces
are all very well coordinated and if you
really dissect the position you'll see
it's just the Rook that's attacking a
night and none of whites other pieces
are actually remotely involved in the
attack
yeah uh at the moment black has perfect
centralization as well with the porn
queen and Knight just saw that tweet
where someone described me as the Susie
Dent of Chess so apparently I'm the
Rachel Riley
I wish
and the Rick defends the night it's a
very English
about countdown um TV show
so The Rook now defends the Black
Knights how can kakash keep the momentum
going before it's too late
Something's Happened
um it did feel a bit wrong for Magnus to
play this move I actually thought Magnus
had something a bit stronger but what is
in there
Rook takes E7 is a threat in Queen d8
wow
and actually if we look at this if the
Knight moves suddenly there's either a
knight H5 or queen B7 shot and that's
just over so for example this and you
come in and you get to the black king
that's just like that no reaction on
Magnus but he obviously has blunder
is seeing it now I think he's starting
to realize
um it's not actually obvious I mean if
you showed me this position even after
white brings the queen in I would be
thinking okay there must be a defense
for black
but the computer confirms that there
isn't one and just to show the threats
as you guys mentioned if black for
example takes a pawn then white will
play Rook takes Knight and actually this
is background Checkmate uh the king is
trapped and okay you can throw a rook in
the way but it doesn't change anything
this is Checkmate on the next move and
yeah he's a threat look at look at
magnus's face he's he's it's dawned on
him it took him also about 20 30 seconds
to realize hold on a second am I busted
here and ironically in the previous move
he was completely winning he just had to
play Knight G6
um
in the previous move yeah Knight G6 and
I guess the difference here is that
uh uh if Knight H5 here maybe black can
go in the attack before white does yeah
exactly you just take this Pawn you
threaten checkmate
it still looks a bit scary that you
allow the white Rook to check but maybe
blacks you're just there quicker just in
time just in time but he was too slow he
played a defensive move in this position
but going back to the game position I
mean there we see Magnus with his head
in his hands okay he's done or Dawning
on him but what about if the king just
uh protects the Knight I mean where is
the killer blow the king defends so The
Rook takes Knight the whole idea is you
just go well Rook takes work and
and now you're ready to block any checks
yeah
it feels very shaky it felt like you
know it is hanging by a thread but where
is The Knockout Punch
move putting the
k eight
you can also play Knight D3 here is the
queen trapped wow Lawrence
Queen is actually trapped in the center
and the Queen on B6 protects the E6 Pawn
that's that's a crucial thing yeah so
that's the real threat that's the actual
threat yeah and that's where Magnus
Magnus is now doing his favorite
telling himself off
but it's too late it's too late it's
just it's really over there's no saving
this because Knight D3 as the secondary
the secondary threat is to win the queen
um which is quite good and the queen
Kaya nothing more pleasurable than
trapping a queen in the middle of the
board because you don't expect the queen
to have no squares in the middle of the
board but stone cold in the center it's
just over every square is covered right
yeah these squares are covered by the
White Knight in Queen this is covered by
the White Queen these are all covered by
white Knights and and these are all
covered too there's literally no safe
Square
she's gone wow
16 years old about to beat Magnus
Carlsen
yeah there's there's no coming back from
this is it sometimes you know like even
yet do you remember on day one where
Magnus had uh the bad position against
uh Kamer right and it was losing but the
counter chances were still there this is
just not a position where any counter
chances exist and you can see him he's
he's really annoyed because he knows the
opening went well
um he knows he's going to be on the
front page of many Indian newspapers
tomorrow
ever
possible because his uh kakash is just
16 years old 34 and how old was Prague
he was 16 points something
right and Cash's birthday is in May if
that helps May 2000 yeah no so we know
he is 16.34 so that will be younger
because Prague beat Magnus for the first
time in
February was it yeah he's born in August
okay so it will be so there will be yeah
wow good question will be the youngest
player in history to beat Magnus Carlsen
after he became world champion
incredible these young Indians reaction
from him you know he's just cursing and
he knows it's all over it's gone one
slip up that was it and uh just like a
house of cards his position just
completely fell apart and he had 12
minutes when he blundered uh I mean he
would have known he was doing well
Magnus you can see he knew he was almost
winning or at least a pawn or two up for
nothing
and yeah we've all been there we've all
blundered but it is a bit careless maybe
to
to blunder Without Really pausing for
thought without looking for the
opponent's moves without calculating oh
he just wants to hide Magnus Carlsen he
hates the way he made that blunder and
imagine for cash sistering there waiting
now for six minutes
to make his move it's a shame his camera
is so dark because I would have liked to
have seen
special
expression Magnus is giving us a lot of
facial expressions Magnus is going
through the whole range of emotions but
uh kakash wow he's just calm and uh well
spotted you know Fair Play Take a cash
for just seizing this opportunity when
it was presented to him because was that
difficult obviously when Magnus made
this blundercash has answered with a
mold I mean it only becomes obvious once
you see it really I mean it took us a
while to realize especially the second
threat one threat was obvious Rook takes
nights that one is Crystal Clear maybe
Magnus even spotted that but I think he
must have missed
um the second threat of trapping the
black queen and
um yeah I mean even when kukesh played
that move with five minutes or six
minutes left when gokesh played that
move he won't have been 100 sure he's
winning he would have thought okay I've
got two threats maybe the opponent has
something some way to deal with it but
now he sees stop for six seven minutes
he's gonna be
I mean firstly calculating realizing
black has no defense but he's going to
be full of confidence that he's going to
finish this off now and I'm just trying
to find a way that defends even a few
more moves and I just can't there
there's just no move it's just really
over and I think Magnus will actually
resign
yeah I think he's just going to resign I
think he's just
so very relative I've seen him so
irritated I just checked the computer
evaluations to see whether there was any
way to extract the queen from danger
nope
basically he's saying yeah nothing you
can do eventually you're gonna have to
no he does my queen takes work but now
Brooke takes nights
as Lawrence pointed out earlier that's
on the board and that's going to be just
devastating for the world champion yeah
just to show Once More this this Rook is
poisoned it cannot be captured because
of Checkmate in two moves this is deadly
uh this is a check the black king has no
Escape squares uh thanks to this white
porn actually this white porn doing a
good job of cutting it off and Checkmate
so Magnus had to run away with this Rook
but now he's a whole piece down and uh
the attack is likely to continue uh I
mean that's surely going to be an attack
against the black king on two squares
you can offer a trade of Queens yeah try
to put it in the bank as I like to say
do we want to trade off the Queens do we
not want to go for checkmate
I like the swelling in his chat doesn't
even want to look at this Magnus Carlsen
yeah so you guys are suggesting for
example this move yeah
firstly coin trade secondly going for
this Pawn just remember that there's a
Pawn on E6
yeah maybe this is a good move maybe
Magnus looks like a great move to yeah
maybe magnus's one trap is after Quinn
to this Square yeah he'll give a check I
guess and maybe he'll take the White
Knight
um because if the queen is captured now
then suddenly it's white who gets
checkmated along the back rank but
um also just to show that this is just
one check the black king can suddenly
hide in the corner but you've got cash
won't fall for that one
and uh yeah in the current position this
looks like a immediate win for gokash
Queen's off you just win with your extra
Knight
maybe there are other ways
you just have to make sure you don't
allow a counter-attack against the white
king
shocking really four minutes he should
have this in the back now yeah
I mean he's gonna be he understands he
has to still tread a little carefully
here even though the machine is saying
plus 8.3 uh a bit of care bit of care is
required and look I mean the kid is uh
he's good
he just finds the way and here actually
Magnus is obliged to trade Queens Queen
E3 checking H1 and there's no there's no
follow-up actually the key difference
now is that the White Queen protects her
Knight on F4 right so that trick we saw
in the last variation just doesn't work
also I want to point out like let's say
queen E3 check King H1 let's say Rook
takes B2 just to try and get a nice
little mate in four here Rook takes H7
we're probably gonna see it Laura the
king is going to go to the corner and uh
well since you're a piece down you might
as well for example going for checkmate
yeah yeah
and now a lovely Rook takes Pawn again
just removing a key Defender Knight G6
and it's over seven is a mate it is over
Magnus Carlsen loses to another Indian
teenager it's a massive win